hey it's stephanie wong and welcome back
to what's new in networking where we
cover what's new in networking today i'm
covering the updates for core
infrastructure there's a lot to catch up
on so let's get into it
[Music]
right off the bat we have some exciting
cloud region announcements we've
launched new cloud regions in delhi
india melbourne australia and warsaw
poland delhi and melbourne are the
second regions within those markets
enabling in-country disaster recovery
for mission-critical applications
meanwhile warsaw is the first region in
poland and the seventh in europe
designed for high availability regions
open with three availability zones to
protect against service disruptions and
offer a portfolio of our key products
including compute engine kubernetes
engine cloud storage cloud spanner and
bigquery
if you deploy workloads in those regions
you'll benefit from lower latency and
high availability for your users
we're also expanding our interconnect
locations including phoenix arizona
minneapolis minnesota copenhagen denmark
and warsaw poland adding to over 110
locations
dedicated interconnect provides direct
physical connection between your
on-premises network and google's network
dedicated interconnect enables you to
transfer large amounts of data between
networks which can be more cost
effective than purchasing additional
bandwidth over the public internet
with additional locations we're making
it more accessible for you to get direct
physical connection from your own
network to google's including up to a
hundred gigabits per second circuit next
up cloud router's new features cloud
router is our fully managed service that
uses border gateway protocol bgp to
advertise ip address ranges like you saw
in the last section it's used to set up
dedicated interconnect as well as high
availability vpn and serves as a control
plane for cloud nat
you can now disable or enable a bgp
session on cloud router at a per peer
level previously you were not able to
enable or disable specific bgp sessions
on cloud router
you can now do so by issuing a command
through the api cli gcloud or the google
cloud ui without terminating the bgp
session
say you've set up cloud router but you
want to change the router configuration
when migrating to a different bgp pier
or performing maintenance on appear
you can disable the session per pier
safely with a quick command update the
settings and enable the session
this gives you the flexibility to make
configuration changes per appear without
resetting the bgp session or disabling
and re-enabling the interconnect or vpn
link it sits on
now let's talk about the keep alive
timer the cloud router and your
on-premise router maintain communication
by using timer settings
the keep alive timer is the interval
between periodic pgp heartbeat messages
exchanged between a cloud router and the
on-premises router and indicates whether
a router is reachable to its bgp pier
you can now modify the keep a live timer
on cloud router previously it was static
with a default value of 20 seconds but
now you can change it to a value between
20 and 60 seconds
this way you can set a higher value on
the google cloud side in case you have a
longer hold timer before a failure is
triggered
once the whole timer is hit the bgp
session is torn down
one thing to note is we recommend
setting the keep alive timers to the
same value on your on-premises router
and the cloud router
together these features provide you with
flexibility in managing and
troubleshooting bgp sessions with cloud
router
serverless vpc access allows you to
create vpc connectors that connect
serverless services like app engine
cloud run and cloud functions to a vpc
network when you create a connector in
your google cloud project you attach it
to a specific vpc network and region you
can then configure your serverless
services to use the connector for
outbound network traffic like accessing
compute engine instances and any other
resources with an internal ip address
while serverless vpc access
automatically provisions throughput for
a connector in 100 megabits per second
increments based on the amount of
traffic sent through
you could still phase throughput limits
if the connector was deployed using a
smaller machine type
with this update you can select larger
instances to support more throughput and
set new scaling settings
you can set the connector machine type
and the min and max number of instances
it can scale to if traffic requires it
the connector can scale up to the max
number configured with the update you
can achieve up to 16 gigabits per second
of throughput by specifying a larger
machine type
that's it for networking updates for
core infrastructure
check out the links to learn more and
stay tuned for our next episode of
what's new in networking